republican congressman mo brooks hoists
himself on his
own pitard by screwing himself out of
getting a defense from the government
you might recall that eric swalwell has
filed a lawsuit against some of the
people he believes are responsible for
the january 6 insurrection
congressman mo brooks tried to get out
of this suit by invoking the westfall
act which basically says you can't sue a
government official for acts that occur
during the course and scope of their
governmental duties and if the westfall
act applies this is complicated but
effectively the official just gets
dismissed from the suit now mo brooks
claimed that when he was making his
speech on january 6 this was in the
course and scope of his duties as a
congressman but
in trying to defeat the lawsuit itself
and invoke this
privilege he said that he was basically
making political campaign speeches and
there are all kinds of regulations that
say a sitting congress person cannot
make campaign speeches
in the course and scope of their duties
as an elected official so by moe
brooks's own sworn testimony the
westflag doesn't apply
and the doj is not going to defend him
so we will definitely be seeing mo
brooks
in court